una nueva restricción en contra de los
palestinos el nuevo gobierno del
ultraderechista Benjamín netanyahu y
suministro de seguridad nacional
ordenaron a la policía israelí
prohibieron dejar banderas palestinas en
espacios públicos por lo que muchos han
salido a las calles de Jerusalén del
este a manifestarse
no nos rendiremos dicen que la bandera
del pueblo palestino es la bandera del
terrorismo pero esta bandera representa
al pueblo es una bandera que representa
una lucha por la libertad la igualdad la
paz y la justicia
organizaciones internacionales han
calificado de represiva esta nueva
medida que hace parte del anuncio de
netanyahu con el cual pretende realizar
una reforma judicial que busca reducir
los poderes de la Corte Suprema y
limitar su independencia para dar a los
políticos un papel más importante dentro
de la elección de los principales jueces
del país
alarmando a los opositores que temen que
se fracture la democracia y los derechos
de las minorías
[Música]
creo que todos aquí están de acuerdo en
que se necesita una reforma pero el peso
general de estas reformas y la forma en
que se han presentado va a politizar la
corte politizar las funciones de los
asesores legales y de hecho eliminar los
únicos controles y equilibrios que
tenemos en nuestra democracia
se espera que las manifestaciones en
contra de la Reforma continúen Durante
los próximos días mientras que netanyahu
ha hecho un llamado a la calma y pedido
apoyo popular para su plan